let me pull up this story from the Daily
Mail check this one out JFK director
Oliver Stone says he made a mistake
voting for Joe Biden in 2020 because he
fears president will start World War III
with his support for Ukraine
there you go he said quote if we don't
stop this what Biden is doing this guy I
voted for him I made a mistake I was
thinking he was an old man now and then
he would calm down that he would be more
mellow and so forth I didn't see that at
all I see a man who maybe is not in
charge of his own Administration who
knows it seems that he's dragging a
stupid Lane to a confrontation with a
power that is not going to give this is
their borders this is their world this
is NATO going into Ukraine this is their
whole other story he's right imagine
what would happen if China went into
Mexico and took large portions of its
government and started putting troops
and sending weapons the U.S would go
nuts I just saw no the U.S and we did
because there's literally I just saw a
tweet by someone that was talking about
uh Chinese uh police stations here in
the U.S policing the Chinese people yeah
bio labs and stuff here in the US I
don't think that the American people I
really think that as much as there are
people that complain a lot on the
internet and stuff I really think that
Americans are way too comfortable to get
really really Buck Wild and in like some
kind of revolutionary way they'll get
out in the streets and they'll you know
throw rocks and stuff and and throw them
all tops and try and get into fights
with the police but that's only the most
mentally
questionable or or at risk if you want
to call them that um people that the
average people your average person has
even the people that have it bad have it
better than most humans in human history
I just don't see the the Revolutionary
energy that that what's your point
though with China you just mean like the
fact that people are not angry about it
yeah there's Chinese you know there's
they're they're talking about building a
Chinese uh listening Post in Cuba
there's actual Chinese
um
I guess government police that are
policing Chinese
uh former Chinese citizens
there's HIV and China's done the same
thing in Canada that they violated if
the United States actually took the
Monroe Doctrine seriously anymore there
would be there would be at least some
type of retaliation between all this
stuff that we talked about that we've
mentioned in the past five minutes or
whatever and the the Spy balloon that
went over and stuff
I understand that most Libertarians are
like you know we shouldn't be looking
for for problems with other countries
and I agree
when you got a country sending a police
force into your borders and policing
citizens of your your country from a
foreign country I get it that you your
anti-war Libertarians but hey at some
point the the the actual sovereignty of
your country matters even if you have
open borders well so I agree and I get
like we should be moderately upset about
those things but I think on this on the
scale of like I agree there's no
revolutionary energy but like I I'm way
more concerned about like this war we're
talking about what Roger Stone's talking
about about blowing up the world like if
there's a Chinese police station in my
local city
um that is pretty weird and concerning
but I'm much more concerned with like my
president potentially being blackmailed
by Ukraine and then therefore looping me
into a nuclear war that could literally
kill me one day
um where the Revolutionary energy needs
to be focused and and I agree there's a
lack of it it could simply be blackmail
that Hunter Biden's on the board of
barisma Dad Evan Archer calls DC says we
want the prosecutor fired the the the
the Elites in the oligarchs the people
in Ukraine know exactly what Joe Biden
did and then they call him up and say
we're gonna spill the beans unless you
give us what we want yeah no I I I I've
like gamed that out in my head as well I
think it could exactly be that and it's
just crazy and you know we should all
come together as a country and just say
Joe whatever they got on you it's
totally fine we're not going to judge
let the blackmail come out we'd much
rather I'd much rather see a naked photo
of Joe and like it's not that well it's
going to be evidence it's going to be
felonies right no I know multiple I was
going to say with addition I was going
to say like a naked photo of him with a
kid but like let's just let that come
out and just end the war man it's more
important support pardoning Joe Biden to
end the war yeah or just in general just
even preemptively with no expectation of
anything after would you
um I don't
uh with just for no reason
assuming that there's gonna stuff is
going to come out later is why my reason
would be but would you do it not with
any expectation or like tit-for-tat just
be like no oh would I do it right now
hoping like the war hoping there is
Black Mountain hoping the war ends or
yeah or for any reason would you yes I
would yes for any reason yeah I see I
see what you're saying yeah I would do
it for that reason
for no reason well you're not really I
can't tell if you're saying no reason I
mean if there's no reason I'm not as
concerned with the reason I'm just
asking if you would do it
there are reasons where I would do it
and that was one of them but if you have
I think if it is like an IP chess all
these pardons that we got to do I see no
other way forward if you haven't been
partying no you have you have a tribunal
if we know for a fact that he was
engaged in illicit activities then he is
criminally charged if if you have no
need to Pardon him if you have the
pardoning power you simply just indict
him
you could do that indict and then pardon
him why would you pardon him
so that we don't have this Tit for Tat
so that the Next Generation yeah for you
Hunter's sister doesn't come back with
guns up you know you don't want to just
keep the cycle 100 sister yeah I
wouldn't be worried about that but yeah
I agree in terms of like for I mean
don't agree with the idea that by
allowing Elite criminals to get away
with their crimes you actually stopped
the crime well what you do want to do is
expose them and make the world know what
they did but then pardon them but if
yeah if you expose them and they and the
world knows what they did and then you
pardon them that is not going to
disincentivize people from doing the
same in the future I don't know if
anything can disincentivize it yeah all
the incentives are in their favor
Guillotines well yeah but that didn't
work well in the French Revolution
because like who's in control of the
guillotine like who's deciding the guy
ultimately got his head cut off yeah
that's right not just him but you know
there's the threat of force I mean the
threat of force is usually the go-to
like how do you stop corrupt leaders
from being corrupt if it's a divorce and
if it's treason there's varying degrees
of punishment
well I I think but I think I think on
some level you can like it's not only
doesn't only have to be punishment and I
guess Ian what you might be getting at
is like you can appeal I I imagine in
theory like you can appeal to the
humanity of these people like I know
like you know Lindsey Graham to me does
not seem like a guy who has much
Humanity in him
um Joe Biden I mean that hugely Brazen
corrupt kind of that Mafia display is
like is awful but like when you also
listen to that clip of him remember when
that that clip of him came out of like a
voicemail on Hunter's phone and he's
like son I love you you know we'll get
over this drug addiction or whatever to
me that sounded like
um I guess Dad who loved his son so I
think I think that's naive it's naive to
think like I can use I can like I can
like tap into that
um Humanity of Joe Biden but I'm just
saying it's there and he feels love for
his son
um
but but yeah and and maybe there is some
way to tap into that like I don't know
if that's what you're getting at with
the pardons but
um I always won't solve it so
I'm just saying one day and says like
God you know I do have these
grandchildren and like I don't want to I
don't I don't want to blow up the war
what I don't want to blow up the world
because I want my grandchildren to live
a nice life I I hope that deep down he's
thinking something like that I'm not you
know I'm not gonna Bank on it but I'm
hoping it's there that that sentiment no
I think he's more thinking I will burn
the world to the ground before I lose
power you think Biden thinks that way I
think he thinks to a certain degree that
way I don't think he's the most ruthless
guy ever he's he's bit he's just a
corrupt guy but these people tend to
have an attitude
corrupt individuals are corrupt because
their attitude is usually the whole
world will burn before I lose I don't
know if he's that strong of an
but you've heard like that nobody
with a Biden hot Mike quote from him
no when was that I I forget I think it
might have been at the DeSantis presser
he had but you guys really think he
thinks that much at all well that yeah I
mean that's another one just because
he's old now doesn't mean he did not
build his life and his family off of
these ideas that he will take whatever
he wants right this is look you wonder
why it is almost every every politician
is a bad person it's because good people
don't have what it takes to manipulate
everyone around them to gain political
power
right that's a good point and and and I
got I I do have that naive streak in me
because I got to be honest so before I
was into politics like during the
coveted era I barely read the news at
all and um I I like liked Anthony fauci
like I would watch the news and I was
like you know I kind of like this guy
like his raspy voice he's kind of
charismatic and and recently I um read
the real Anthony fauci by Robert F
Kennedy and it was mind-blowing to see
like when you when you learn about
everything in that book from the whole
like AIDS pandemic and how like the
chemo drug that they were prescribing
was basically causing AIDS or making it
way worse
AZT and him experimenting on Orphan on
orphans like killing hundreds of Orphan
children and debilitating many more when
you realize that that guy can go on TV
and like Smooth talk the entire world
um smooth talk like it's kind of what
Tim is saying and it's like Jesus like
that's a level of like psychopath that I
can't even imagine
indeed must you think like the
psychopath to defeat the psychopath
there's the one thing that I want to say
is like you you talk you know a lot
about like forgiveness and stuff like
that and and I I am so like I said
earlier like I'm so black pilled about
even being able to communicate with
people it's such and I maybe it just
struck me that like you're you're still
looking for ways to find EX to expect
good behavior from people or to offer
people the option of Behaving well uh
and I just don't think that they're
gonna yeah you know I'm obsessed not
really so Ben Franklin is a big
inspiration and that guy always had like
a twinkle in his eye and kind of a
knowing smile like we already won
um so he was like a diplomat yeah Ben he
knew the whole time he was like the
father of the Rebellion the father of
the United States essentially like
everyone looked up to him as a soul dude
how do you know he had a twinkle in his
eye did people write that down I I in
the pictures I've seen of I mean I think
maybe they do he was just yeah the
paintings and the stuff he just he's so
jovial and he's an inventor he's a
brilliant and like he knew his morale
was so high I think he just instilled
the morale of the nation with his with
his books and his communication style so
I hopefully somebody people can do that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time